[Música]
bajo las aguas de este río al alcance de
la mano
polvo de oro
con ayuda de un material rudimentario
estos buscadores de oro tratan de
separar el metal de los residuos del
torrente desde hace varios meses cada
vez son más numerosos en probar suerte
en este río del sur de tailandia
aquí en menos de un gramo unos quince
euros el precio del oro ha aumentado
entonces con ello puedo comprar con que
comer
la región fronteriza con malasia lleva
el sobrenombre de montaña de oro
[Música]
la búsqueda de este metal es una
actividad ancestral que se volvió vital
de nuevo para los habitantes del sector
hasta el año pasado vivían de los
oficios del turismo o del comercio
es lo único que podemos hacer en este
momento no hay otro trabajo venimos aquí
a buscar oro usamos nuestras manos no
hay máquinas es un trabajo físico
esto es para quitar piedras las echamos
allá luego el polvo de oro de méxico la
tierra antes del cobre dado madre de
cinco niños le vendía ensaladas de
papaya a los turistas
hoy girando su batea en la superficie
del agua espera ver aparecer los
reflejos dorados sinónimo de comida para
sus hijos cuando venimos todos juntos
así podemos recoger más de un gramo
un trabajo familiar
esta estudiante universitaria vino a
ayudar a su comunidad
aprendí a hacerlo cuando era pequeña me
gusta
depende sabores
hay días en los que encontramos muchos
otros no depende en este pueblo de 300
habitantes privados del vaivén de los
turistas impera la calma salvo donde la
compradora de oro que ve cada vez más
gente pasar por su casa el verano pasado
el precio del metal amarillo batió
récords a cerca de 50 euros el gramo hoy
en día contra 30 euros hace dos años se
volvió un valor refugio para los
inversionistas estoy contenta puedo
comprar con qué comer hoy obtuve cerca
de 900 bats 900 bats 25 euros el precio
está muy elevado por estos días y sigue
aumentando la recolección del día del
pueblo cerca de 50 gramos que partirán a
bangkok para fabricar joyas hace 10 o 20
años había mucho sólo debía agacharse
para recogerlo hoy en día es más difícil
hay muchos y no busca vender a todos los
días esta región bendecida por el oro
atraía de los turistas deseosos de
evitar las playas atestadas del sur el
pueblo había invertido en el ecoturismo
un proyecto de teleférico estaba en
construcción
pero está en pausa hoy en día esta será
la solución para desarrollar el turismo
en nuestros pueblos el circuito del
teleférico unida a la montaña y el
templo y culminará al pie de la montaña
en frente
un contador turístico en cero por ahora
hoy la estudiante que encontramos en el
río era guía medio tiempo extraña de los
visitantes
el kayak tal como las otras actividades
está suspendido antes teníamos hasta 150
clientes al día ayer la actividad abrió
por primera vez pero había tan solo
cuatro o cinco turistas es muy poco este
festival la cia venir a mucha gente
teníamos circuitos para que los turistas
debutarán en esto de la búsqueda de oro
pero se aventura en la selva con
frecuencia para verificar que la galería
de la antigua mina francesa no se hayan
derrumbado en los años 30 una concesión
había sido atribuida a francia
antes de la crisis muchos turistas
venían a visitar esta mina porque a la
gente que venía a nuestra región le
gustaba la naturaleza y la aventura
los mineros iluminaban la roca y la
raspaban cuando tenían polvo de oro en
sus dedos sabían que era un buen lugar
los turistas se han ido y ahora en su
lugar hay serpientes
estoy segura en un futuro quiero ser
guía turística
tras haber vendido su oro
está o regreso a casa para ocuparse de
sus hijos que regresaron de la escuela
a veces vienen a buscar oro los fines de
semana en semana van a la escuela
quiero ser oficial de marina
porque no se me hace soñar
harán lo que quieran hasta que
envejezcamos y muramos sabemos que
nuestros hijos tendrán con queso existir
aquí porque hay oro selva montañas ríos
la naturaleza es generosa
a la espera del regreso de los turistas
[Música]
los padres de estos niños tienen las
esperanzas puesta en el río dorado
[Música]